byzo are you gonna miss us no he's like
good
riddance they're like yes parents are
about to leave it's gonna be a party up
in this house
good morning everyone good morning
why are you dressed like this huh where
are we very cool here i don't know whose
house it is
it's a very nice house though we're
staying at a place in
denver colorado we're in denver now
so yesterday we flew in and
we left our kitties all alone isaac
stayed behind with his dad
because he's a teenager now so he's like
i don't want to go on a trip
flexing his responsibility legs too and
he's like i'm gonna i'm gonna cast it
for you guys yeah
for you guys so he is actually gonna
house it for us that's pretty cool we
recently got tested for covid just in
case you guys are wondering because you
guys are probably thinking how
irresponsible we are but we're not we
got tested we're negative and so we
planned this trip with the chan clan
oh we planned this trip way before the
the reason the second wave
yeah we did we was like it started
spiking like all crap
exactly we totally did book this like
months ago we're just like
the closer it got to the date we're like
oh no oh no
so it was actually really scary too
because as you guys i'm sure you know
like fart tested positive for kovid but
luckily from the last day that we saw
bart
to the day that he got tested that was
seven days
or eight days i think it was eight days
eight days that we like hadn't seen him
so we're like okay we should be good but
then we still got tested anyways just to
be safe and luckily we were negative
and actually casey and i got home
because it was just us two that got
tested
and then isaac when he came home he was
like oh so what'd you guys get
we decided to play a prank on him in the
room
yeah yeah
[Music]
stay back
is it a false scope it actually is a
false name or
like is it a false i don't know it's
positive
yeah if this positive is positive it's
negative it may be
false negative yeah
[ __ ] if you're wearing my mask probably
don't have coffee
we might need to get yeah we might need
you to test too
yeah it hurts it does it hurts a lot
oh
[Applause]
you're like wait do you like them so we
ended up pranking him
we're good we're clean and so we decided
to come on this trip
and on this trip it was very interesting
because we
we did have to take two flights we had a
layover
but so the first flight was like super
empty it was only 20 people on the whole
flight or something
and then but then the second flight was
another story and
that flight got me a little nervous but
we were
like we never took off our mask we
didn't touch anything
i didn't drink that water i'm so
dehydrated yeah we did not like drink
anything just in case
because we're like i don't know who has
what in this plane but as of now i mean
it has only been a day but i feel fine i
think we're okay
uh we've been very safe and yeah we're
just really looking forward to
spending this trip with the chain
cleaning some family
yes yeah look how good you look dude i
really like it thank you
i love this look today this is uh
courtesy of my wife my beautiful wife
and then this scarf is producing my my
my dad
you're gonna see your beautiful dad good
morning everybody
stanford yeah right
yeah you know what's so funny last night
we're trying to find some beers for you
and you wanted some local brews and so
we're in the
beer aisle and then we're like all right
so uh what what
what's with the denver brew what's the
colorado brew and then tiff kept
pointing out like oh
that was that one about one and
that was so funny because yeah i was
just like oh look a local brew from
oregon there we go that should work
right that was so funny
like portland artisanal yeah
oh yeah it's perm do you like it or not
yeah english very british
member cheerio
okay well we're about to head out but
before we leave though i do want to show
you
look at this wow there's so much snow
here it's actually 16 degrees today
like we just checked the weather and
it's 16 degrees it's cold i carry
oh your camera's nice thanks it's a new
one oh man i'm jealous i have the sony
oh that was our old yeah our old one
mark
five or no i don't know the fifth one
whatever they call it
yeah we i switched over to canon that
one looks like all vintage retro so
you're ready for denver look at you you
look like
you look like you're from alaska we've
been watching a lot of fargo
so i'm trying to look like i'm from
minnesota
i nailed it i like your hat it looks
cool i bought this in taiwan and
when i bought it i was just waiting for
the day i could wear this oh perfect
yeah today's the day hi mama and diana
good morning you guys are nice and warm
what's happening here
let's go what is this
you have like a blanket hoodie oh talk
about your jacket
so basically you put a power bank and
insert into here and then you turn on
the button
a power button on button right here yeah
oh my gosh
and then warm on my back that is so
high-tech
in here that's so cool you always have
the coolest high-tech stuff like even
your glasses how they come apart with a
magnet do you still have those
no i don't have it oh with you okay
it's more convenient oh that's good my
glasses right now
uh-oh you gotta find your glasses this
man is always forgetting his glasses
whoa look at oops look at how look mommy
shoes
well look at all this it's a winter
wonderland
yeah i forgot to bring my sunglasses uh
oh i brought mine
oh you don't think about that when you
go to snowy oh i do
i brought them it's so bright i think
you should start like skiing
skiing yep so look i'm bringing an extra
jacket
i have my beanie my gloves let me show
you everything else i'm wearing
so i have my scarf i have this new coat
that i got
from tommy and then there's like this
thin sweater thingy and then i have a
thermal here and then i have another
like spaghetti strap shirt
here and then i'm wearing these north
face leggings
they're like thermal leggings and then
underneath that
another pair of leggings and then for my
socks i have these really thick wool
socks
are you vlogging me vlogging yeah
telling them everything i'm wearing what
are
the layers you're wearing i'm not gonna
tell you oh it's a secret
it's private you look like a star wars
character he looks like candy from south
park
i don't even know what he looks like i
never watched one of the streams if it
was orange
then you would look exactly like him oh
and then also i am wearing these
boots that we took to iceland and
portland oh yeah you're wearing them too
right yeah i'm pretty much wearing are
you guys bringing a lot of iceman stuff
yeah yeah carrie oh my god we can never
leave you
oh my god my hands are freezing as i'm
vlogging i'm gonna wear these i know
mama was trying to leave at 8 30 but now
it's
nine ish i don't know 9 20 something
it's practically 9 30
9 15. there we go 9 15. sorry mama
you wanted to go explore okay a bunch of
kids yeah i know that's what happens
when you have
a lot of adults who are still children
trying to get ready but she made a whole
list of things
that we can try to see that is like
covet friendly and outdoors because
we're in the middle of a pandemic but
we're still
finding ways to have some family time
and explore denver right right
yes
[Music]
all right we're all packed up in the car
i'm with diana
and diana brought her sister rachel yay
so we actually switched out isaac for
rachel because we're still
seven trying clan seven because even
though i just went here
and so we got rachel so yay where are we
heading now guys
glamour square it sounds like you're
speaking french larimer square
he loves french today yeah he does he
looks very european right the only thing
know how to say in french is uh leticia
bonjour and then uh bonsoir
oh yeah how was brazil for you guys it
was nice
yeah yeah it was a lot warmer than here
definitely
that was cool you guys got to see the
amazon yeah i'm jealous
i want to make i want to do that trip
too i still have a mosquito bite you
still
eat after two weeks a month
a month i'm like wait you weren't in
brazil two weeks ago
a month oh three weeks ago a month ago
it was a month
at least of today oh my goodness so
you get it checked it out checked out
[Music]
i'm really digging the architecture here
because everything looks like it's still
stuck in like the 1800s kind of it's
kind of cool
now we're going to try to find somewhere
to eat because we're hungry
but as of right now just by driving by
the city
it looks like everything is closed like
completely close closing
it's a monday morning by the way
everything seems dead
so not surprising
[Music]
okay look at i just turned on my heater
on the jacket
it's like iron man yeah
that looks like iron man stuff right
there you just have to have it in the
center instead of right here
yeah is it heating up not yet where does
it heat it up
on the back right here take out all the
teeth
oh yeah i could feel it getting warmer
we don't know how heated
jacket true we don't we're cold my toes
are cold
the shoes are made out of wool and so
are my socks but it's still cold
so you don't have a battery i know i
need to do
i need to get that i did see that they
have insoles for your shoes that can
heat up so that's pretty cool all right
so
here's the predicament that we're in all
the places he's calling says take out
only
two yeah i figured him to go back home
and eat
or we could just eat at a park or
something and be freezing cold very true
that sounds funny in the car yeah
that's all we do do you think that
mcdonald's chair have elk burgers
meat or bison meat or whatever like
weird game meats because they're known
for that out here i'm not going home
without trying that
yeah but it doesn't seem like any place
is open
i've got a winner is it busy right now
we can take care of you
okay thank you we'll be there in about
10 minutes all right as new as it is
all right thank you so much
[Music]
all right so after we had breakfast
we went to this restaurant that was by
union
station that's the word i always want to
call it square
oh yeah we went to union station and
there was a really good restaurant there
really delicious breakfast and then
afterwards
we came here so now we're here at this
place called
i guess red rock something i don't know
but the rocks are the rocks are really
red
so it's inappropriate they are colorado
yeah we learned
last night from our spanish members or
mexican members
of our family group of the group that
colorado means
in red yeah it just means like colored
like red colored so
that's what that means yeah right now we
just wanted to see some nature
so we're hiking sort of and exploring
there's a lot of snow everywhere
so i'm really glad we brought these
boots so true
iceland came in handy yeah the residual
iceland experience
aka colorado yep colorado sounds like it
would be the color auto
wait what's the color auto oh yeah they
really look like
what color is auto i don't know color
color
wait did you almost lift this up yeah
okay maybe i'm holding on to this let's
just travel on this side
yep dang i'm out of shape man
i should work out just for endurance
while i travel
oh this behind you it's beautiful
turning back back
where you came from it's not it's always
important to know where you came from
yes
unless the places you're going forward
to are even better which i'm thinking
right about that
that that top part amazing
yep in that case you never look back
it's hard to keep up with you
while you're talking and like walking so
i'm like okay you keep talking i'm
staying here
here's the altitude maybe you're not as
out of shape or we're not as out of
shape as we do that's true wait come
over here how do we do extra work coming
back well it's your fault we're leaving
yeah we're really high up i can't even
breathe hey why am i still wearing this
there's no one around can i get like a
little bit of altitude sickness because
even when we went to
salt lake um i get really dehydrated
yay dude i've been eating better way
more isn't
cold maybe it's the altitude just
kidding
we're not from this altitude you know so
our bodies react differently yeah like
last time when we went to
salt lake it was very very no wait we
didn't go to salt lake city we went to
park city utah
whatever the point is we went to utah it
was really
high elevation and it did get a little
like more difficult
breathing normally because of the
elevation and also
i did get very thirsty and i do feel
those symptoms
right now so i am blaming it on the
elevation it's also
more of a challenge to speak well
climbing all these
steps down kerry said it's the altitude
awesome
[Music]
this mask not only does it protect
against
you know covet stuff
looking over there if i didn't know who
it was i would expect
that to be an old person everyone walks
in the snow
over right everyone's like i know
diana's the one holding on to him i mean
he's holding on to bananas
over here i think our californian is
showing
heck yeah i don't know how to walk over
ice it's okay
i'm not embarrassed i'm proud of
california i'm keeping the camera
rolling in case one of us falls
oh someone peed someone totally keith
someone tried making lemonade
and they did not have enough lemons
gross there's more acne there's a lot
more no it's probably the plant
maybe it's a bird or teeth no it doesn't
look like human pee
what is human there's more right there
you really think they were walking and
peeing i doubt it
someone was peeing i don't think so or
they're trying to make lemonade
never eat yellow ice or snow
yellow snow i mean
[Music]
this is cool what an amazingly unique
amphitheater
it's good to be next dc worker
what built by the ccc workers from 1936
tonight 1941. yeah that's what the
statue said
oh my god oh cool look at them working
out well let me take a photo of this
lowest zoom ever oh now you want to zoom
in all fast oh man now he stops
great he's troubling he's working and
working
okay so we spent a long time
trying to find where the trail begins so
if you ever come to colorado just know
that
this state just does not like signs
because even in the airport
it was impossible for us to even get to
the baggage claim
it was insane but anyway now that we're
here we
started this trail and we're gonna see
what it's like to just
take this cute nice little height
because everything else that we've been
doing up until this point it was just
walking around and then it just so
happened to be at the amphitheater found
the first sign of the trail
yeah so we tried starting the day early
today it was a slow start
but we got it going and then also we had
a lot of setbacks trying to find out
where we could go eat
we finally found a place we could eat
and then we wanted to come here and
check out the red rocks
and we are and we have and we did but
now we're running out of sun
so we're just gonna try to squeeze in
this tiny little trail
and enjoy the last drop of sunlight
before it starts getting dark are you
nice and warm with your jacket yeah nice
careful
just reminds me of iceland it does but a
lot less
ice ice and less scenery yeah not to
take away from colorado but yeah yeah
it is really nice i can carry my mom's
shrieking voice in the back
really where is she like way over there
this is like we're off-roading
it's like it's melting yeah it's like
melted dirt kind of what it looks like
it looks like uh when i when i when i
don't eat my chocolate ice cream fast
enough
oh yeah it's all melted chocolate ice
cream yeah
true no clumps of uh ice ice cream oh
whipped cream whipped cream yes that's
what it is
man isaac would have loved it here look
at this it's a miniature
ice ice skating pond how cute oh damn
that was dangerous
what happened oh he just laid in it
he just laid in the snow just like isaac
true
i kind of want to lift it he lifts it oh
yeah cool
you want to toss it yes nice
the anticipation was that thick and then
you're nice at the end which is it was
worth it
[Music]
nice
[Music]